- [Voiceover] In the last
video, we established that
if we say the rate of
change of a population
with respect to time is
going to be proportional
to the population, we were able to
solve that differential equation,
find a general solution,
which involves an exponential.
That the population is going
to be equal to some constant
times e to some other
constant, times time.
And in the last video we
assumed time was days.
So let's just apply
this, just to feel good
that we can truly model
population this way.
So let's use it with
some concrete numbers.
Once again, you've
probably done that before.
You've probably started
with the assumption
that you can model with
an exponential function,
and then you used some
information, some conditions,
to figure out what the constants are.
You probably did this earlier
in pre-calculus or algebra class.
Let's just do it again,
just so that we can feel
that this thing right over here is useful.
So let's give you some information.
Let's say, that at time equals zero,
the population is equal to 100 insects
or whatever we're measuring
the population of.
And let's say that at time
equals 50, the population,
so after 50 days, the
population is at 200.
So notice it doubled after 50 days.
So given this information,
can we solve for C and k?
I encourage you to pause the video
and try to work through it on your own.
So this first initial
condition's pretty straighforward
to you, because when t is
equal to zero, P is 100.
So we could say, based on this
first piece of information,
we could say that 100 must be equal to
C times e to the k times zero.
Well that's just going
to be e to the zero.
Well e to the zero is just one.
So this is just the same
thing as C times one,
and just like that we have
figured out what C is.
We can now write that the population
is going to be equal to 100e to the kt.
So you can see, expressed this way,
our C is always going to
be our initial population.
So, e to the kt.
And now, we can use this
second piece of information.
So our population is 200,
let's write that down.
when time is equal to 50.
After 50 days.
So 200 is equal to 100e
to the k times 50, right?
t is now 50.
Let me just write that.
k times 50.
Now we can divide both sides by 100,
and we will get, two is
equal to e to the 50k.
Then we can take the
natural log of both sides.
Natural log on the left hand side,
we get the natural log of two.
And on the right hand side, the
natural log of e to the 50k,
well that's just going
to be, that's the power
that you need to raise e
to, to get e to the 50k.
Well that's just going to be 50k.
All you did was took the
natural log of both sides.
Notice, that this equation
that I've just written
expresses the same thing.
Natural log of two is equal to 50k,
that means e to the 50k is equal to two,
which is exactly what
we had written there.
And now we can solve for k.
Divide both sides by 50,
and we are left with,
k is equal to the natural
log of 2, over 50.
And we're done.
We can now write the particular solution
that meets these conditions.
So we can now write that our population,
and I can even write our
population as a function of time,
is going to be equal
to 100 times e to the,
now k is natural log of two
over 50, so I'll write that.
So, natural log of two over
50, and then that times t.
If you assume rate of change of population
is going to be proportional to population,
you assume this information
right over here,
this function is what is going to describe
your growth of population.